only on CBS this morning the father of
kidnapping victim Elizabeth Smart talks
with us about his own personal and
emotional struggle Edie Smart was forced
into the public eye back in 2002 when
his daughter Elizabeth was abducted from
her Salt Lake City bedroom in the middle
of the night she was only 14 years old
now back then smart used his voice to
fight for her miraculous rescue now he's
sharing his own story in our exclusive
interview smart reveals how very
difficult it was to come out as gay to
his family and friends four months ago
and how it's affected his relationship
with his children the thing about it is
I never looked at myself as being gay I
know this sounds crazy it's hard for me
to understand I know I know it's very I
mean I remember guys that kind of came
up to me and I just thought you know
please just get away I you know I've
this is not me this is not me and I felt
like you know this is not where I want
my life to go I've you know gone on a
mission I've you know I'm trying to do
what I'm supposed to do according to the
church according to the church Edie
Smart was tormented with an inner truth
he did not want to tell we really need
your help in finding her including
during the investigation of his daughter
Elizabeth abduction which dominated the
news coverage at the time we love you we
want you to come home safely to us
Elizabeth was kidnapped in June 2002 she
was rescued nine months later found only
a few miles from her Utah home when
Elizabeth was kidnapped you were
certainly front and center of that story
yes while that was going on were you
worried about your secret being revealed
was that of course certain you know here
we are the front page of The Inquirer
did the police at one point view you as
a suspect the thing is is when a child
goes missing the first ones that they
have to look at is the family what was
one of the police theories about
Elizabeth's abduction involving you they
potentially thought that somebody was
blackmailing me I had never heard that
before because you
because I was gay that somehow I was
having this gay affair which was
absolutely not in my mind I thought I've
lost Elizabeth and now I'm losing Louis
and I'm losing my everything that really
means anything to me how can it be that
I have this thing inside of me that I
can't get rid of how difficult has it
been for you now 64 and divorced Smart
has come out with the truth he's been
hiding for most of his life he says that
his family is still processing because
well you've been aware for a long time
of who you are yes then they're just
hearing it for the first time a year ago
right so you have to acknowledge that is
very shocking absolutely horrific what
is your relationship with your children
today I do have a relationship with my
children I know that they're processing
this there yeah probably struggling
through this it's not an easy thing but
I do feel their love and I'm very very
grateful for that it hasn't been an easy
time for anybody really in the smart
family but I was surprised to hear you
know what he says the family is always a
suspect in a case like that oh I did not
know behind the scenes they were really
pressuring him he said he became very
angry with the police yeah for focusing
on that part of the investigation where
he said you know that wasn't that was
not a public thing that anybody knew
that he was gay he knew he's not
involved in some gay sex ring so it was
very very difficult it's understandable
that the police would probe that angle
of it yes I hope to understand that the
issue is not with him but with the
intolerance that he experienced yeah or
that he assumed was there exactly but
it's when it's directed at you Tony it
feels extremely personal and very
incoming it was a very difficult time
for all of them just another reason to
how how tortured he must have been
during that whole process yes and so
important for him to tell those truth
now yeah